I mean I grew up in my dad's couch
and in a normal Council estate
and it was a weekend hobby for me and my
dad we kind of stumbled across it we
started racing RC cars when I was four
right and he thought I had really good
hand to White coordination so he bought
me a go-kart it was really old from a
newspaper and we arrived at the track
for the first time we were not welcome
we were the only first the only black
people there right and um you know and
it was very very expensive so my dad had
four jobs just to keep us going he was
going to London doing his normal job
which was I.T at railroad railroad
station and then he'll come home it'd be
enough for sales signs vending machines
anything he could find a little bit of
cash too because it's so expensive with
my dad well my dad didn't want to want
us to do is to struggle as he did he's
from Grenada came to London and you know
strugged really
um finding money finding a good job so
he's like I don't want my my kids to
struggle like I have so he worked to the
Bone to create an opportunity for us
we dreamed of this as you know when we
were young and when I was young
when we were watching the Grand Prix and
this is way way beyond our dreams and I
think it's so important for kids out
there to hopefully see this and know
that no one's don't listen to anybody
that tells you you can't achieve
something extremely impossible and speak
it into existence and you've got to work
for it you've got to chase it and you've
got to never give up and never doubt
yourself
I've never struggled for motivation in
the sense of
all I can do I can't I can't they're
doing and there's no point worrying or
thinking about what they may or may not
mean all I can do is try and focus on
you know inwards and try to focus on
being the best that I can be what is my
potential how can I be more positive how
can I be have more energy how can I be
healthy how can I be a better person to
be around a better person to work with
so you know I think about all these kind
of things you know naturally I I have
that question and that sometimes that
feeling on with other things
um no I'm not always the most positive
person in the United
I try everything but there's you know
things you try and you you keep failing
and you're like damn I suck and I could
be really negative for a moment and I'm
like oh keep going keep going so I still
have the willpower to get past that that
wall that hits me in the face but when
it comes to driving I
I literally
I've done it my whole life and that's
the thing it's given me so much
confidence
um I get in the car put this helmet on
and I'm able to be
whoever I want to be I can be Superman
under that helmet if I want to be you
know and
um
you know generally when I was at school
I was I was relatively and I was bullied
at school I was I was a little kid and I
and
really know about a big kid so I was
very very much within my cocoon whatever
you want to say you know in my own space
it's very quiet
but when I get in the car I was able to
put out my elbows and stand up for
myself and then eventually I Got
Confidence I was able to help you know
stand up for others
because I went to karate and I got black
belt I could whoop someone's butt which
was amazing so
um yeah but I've never doubted myself in
that and I don't doubt myself
I think it's naturally it's much much
easier to learn
because there's more to learn when you
have failures that's really where the
growth comes from the biggest growth
comes from but there are still ways
you've got to find ways of growing from
the success but I think that's much part
of our working ethic you know we've had
winds come straight back we do our
debrief and we don't skip anything
um I've tried to be as critical and
positive criticism both on the car on
the team's performance but in
also in mind and it's you've got to be
as honest as you can be so I go away
usually
um and over the next few days I'm
looking over the race results looking at
um data I'm looking at because I know in
the race where I could have done better
it could be look at Lane entry it could
be exiting the pit box it could be your
qualifying lap not maximizing it could
be mistakes and time you've lost through
the rates because ultimately you just
you're always chasing time and you don't
like losing time during the rest
so there's there are so many areas and
you're chasing for Perfection and so
there's not been a single race that's
been perfect there's been times where
it's been really close
and it's a great feeling when you feel
close be like still not there so I've
got more if you look around me
personally there's people that are on
their social media all day every day
looking at my phone and forgetting the
rest of the world and not taking time to
see a sunset not taking time to see the
beautiful trees or whatever it is you
know so I'm trying to always find a
balance
um
and mentally it's really about
ultimately feeling good about yourself
is about
finding a way to to make sure you love
yourself you have to really have to love
yourself be comfortable and go so I've
been really spending time trying to
again just take time for me making sure
that I appreciate me I appreciate you
know
acknowledging things that you do well
acknowledging also when you fail and you
don't do it so great it's okay
and not being so hard on yourself all
these different things you know I have
days I wake up and
feel groggy I don't feel motivated to
work out I don't feel
like geez where are we going what is
what's next dude should I continue
racing I think all these different
things
and then I might dare it and then
there'll be another you know the next
hour or whatever it passes I'm like damn
I love what I do why would I ever
consider not continuing
um but as I said you just got to keep
your mind occupied so look I mean life
is a struggle and I think
um I think every day is not it there's
there's failure it's kind of there's
always an opportunity there's potential
for failure
and I feel like we limit ourselves as
human beings I feel like we've got to be
taking risks
um don't fear embarrassment
um don't fear any hardships you know if
you don't if you don't try if you don't
fail you'll never know what your limits
are right you'll you'll be limiting
yourself most of the times believing in
yourself is is one of the I think that's
probably been personally one of the most
important parts there's definitely days
where I feel like a failure there's
believe it or not I feel like a failure
I feel like I'm not good enough there's
days where
um I don't like the way you look or the
way you dress whatever it may be but
believing in yourself learning to love
yourself
yeah and just not giving up you know
that's just never giving up so I think
that's really believing in myself is
really what's enabled me to be to do
what I do on track and then standing up
for what I believe in
and just going with your heart